foreign
yeah let's go to Jen in Perth Australia
gosh I want to say good day mate Jen's
so bad but I'm not going to because I
feel I don't know if I'm allowed to do
that anymore so good morning Jen
good day mate uh yes thank you you're
allowed to do that I'm not so that's
awesome hey what time is it where you
are
oh it's 12 36 A.M
and I did get up out of bed for this oh
I feel I feel so honored I feel so
honored I don't think I would get out of
bed at 12 30 a.m for a fire so thank you
so what's up no thank you you guys have
been very patient with me and taking
this call
um it's been a bit hard to line up but
um
I might I'll just get right to my
question which is how do I let go of
things my husband did while we were
separated
on the backstory there is we were
separated for 18 months it wasn't the
first separation
um when we separated I I'm from North
America and so I went back to North
America
and about three months in to the
separation I asked him if he wanted to
give it another go
and he said no
um I mean I was devastated but I
accepted that and I was over there and
he was here and I my son our teenage son
stayed here with him
um and I just carried on but then it
came to a realization that I needed to
come back to Australia it was in during
the pandemic and I was you know kind of
told by the universe
to get back
to Australia so I did that
and you know we were always very
friendly like it was you know a mutual
separation but I thought
and um
anyway I came back and it was decided
Well before I came back that you know I
would move back into the house and you
would help me get on my feet until I
found a job in my own place and all that
um but when I got back the very first
day
I I found out by my own doing
um that he was seeing somebody
and not just seeing somebody she was
living in the house
oh
whoa welcome home Jen welcome home
yeah I mean he had all obviously asked
her to leave
us that has been going on he had met her
four months prior
and he never told me he put my son in a
position where he had to keep secrets
from me
and why did you get separated I am
well that's a can of worms give me two
or three at the time
um was there abuse was there just not
working out was there no people cheating
on each other what was it
um
bottom line absolute lack of
communication no communication and I
never felt
I never felt cherished by this man did
you ever and he's not on the phone so I
can't talk to him so I'll just talk to
you yeah did you ever give him very
clear understanding or a road map to
what cherished would feel like for you
and here's why I say that some men
myself included absent a road map think
I'm annoying
my the greatest gift I could give my
wife would be to go make a bunch of
money and never come home
and the greatest gift I could give my
wife would be to let her go do whatever
she wants whenever she like that's how
I'll cherish her and it wasn't until
well into my marriage that my wife set
me down or we sat each other down we had
a hard conversation at a Crossroads in
our marriage and said hey this is what
it looks like this is what I need and I
was like man I was way off
and I've got to own that and my wife
owned her part like I haven't made very
clear to you I value you over your money
I'd rather you make way less money be
around here so I tell you that I'd
rather you help me with the dishes than
start lighting candles first right like
whatever the thing is
did you give him a very clear
understanding of here's how you can best
cherish me
yeah probably not we don't communicate
very well I I want to stop in this phone
call stop using the Wii
I want you to take ownership of the
things that you there you go like I
didn't communicate very well he may be
awful at communication if he was on the
phone I'd be letting him have it but
he's not here and so instead of dumping
it all into the Wii bucket and the Wii
bucket and the Wii bucket like man I
didn't communicate well and so we ended
up on a break I feel like this is like a
friend's episode right like we were on a
break
um you're back in you're back in the
home
um kind of the next the next layer here
have you given him very clear
understanding of if we're gonna do this
and go all in
here's what I need I need to see your
phone I you cannot DM any woman who's
not me you can't I want to see bank
accounts have you been very clear on a
road map back or have you just stewed in
your anger
no uh no this is part of my
my problem is ever since we just kind of
I think we got caught up in a moment
okay all right
that that moment of
okay so I found out about the girl I I
ended up staying in the house for a
couple months and then
and I I had to witness him going out on
dates and and all that and it was it was
a very very complicated story
yeah it is complicated but it's actually
oh hold on it is complicated but it's I
don't want to hide behind the complexity
it's pretty simple
uh y'all broke up y'all broke up and you
chose to stay there and by choosing to
stay there
you got he rubbed your nose in all of
his other choices
it's not super complex if you had chosen
to leave and have some self-dignity and
respect and say I'm out and I know
there's I'm making it sound easier than
it is because then you got a kid in the
mix here at least one
um it's not that complex the complexity
is you wanted him to be something he was
not going to be he wanted him to do
something he always want to do and you
wanted to live in that house is that
fair
yes absolutely okay so it is complex
it's messy it's ugly and it's kind of
simple too
so what's your what's your next
what's your next move back together and
we said absolutely no boundaries
okay let's do this and and he said I'm
not going to change and I said fine I'm
not going to change either and that's
where it is I'll show you
yeah yeah
nothing's changed right
well very little I to be honest but it
overall
I guess the the day-to-day relationship
is pretty good but I'm I'm the one still
reliving all this stuff in my head
anytime anything little pops up like I
don't know anything annoying or he
doesn't text me when he's away you weigh
a lot and
um stuff like that then I'm like
what am I doing here like I'm always
like questioning is this where I'm
supposed to be you should be
uh it absolutely should be you have a
completely untethered existence
you have a roommate and y'all are both
decent human beings y'all aren't rude or
ugly or mean or narcissistic lunatics so
you're kind to each other and I bet if a
stranger just a stranger off the street
moved into your house y'all would treat
him the same way you treat each other
like with kindness and hey do you need
any sugar in your tea I mean y'all would
just be kind
that doesn't make for a committed
romantic relationship over the Long Haul
yeah well I brought up the other day
um about how because I I told him
recently that when we need to talk I
need to we need to sit down and have a
chat and I had written out all the
topics that we need to cover and there
was about probably eight things on this
list and I said look I know you don't
have time right now but just look at the
list of what we're going to have to
discuss
and um on the on the list was roommate
the word roommate and he's like oh what
does that mean and I said well it feels
like we're just roommates
and um because that's what it does feel
and he said oh well you know that's all
part of it isn't it
well so I didn't think marriage was part
of being just roommates it's not but
you're you are sitting in a math class
holding an algebra book
and you've never opened the book you've
never talked to the teacher and you're
getting incredibly frustrated that you
don't know algebra
and so you are expecting things of this
marriage
that simply can't be because y'all are
not addressing them head on and from the
just the short part of your story I've
got I've been able to hear
I think you understand what happens if
you set these boundaries he will open
the door and say have a great life I'm
out
I buy those things yeah
like what is keeping you from respecting
yourself like you need to be respected
why don't you demand more from the
universe for you
really
yeah and I don't hold on he's gonna be
mad at you because he lives with a
roommate who hates him
he's gonna be mad with at you because
he's got a
a he co-created a kid
with somebody who
has no backbone
he's getting you're creating a context
where he can't do anything but not like
you
and so you're getting the world you're
creating for yourself and then if you
have boundaries he's not going to hate
you he's just gonna move on
it's you maybe yeah
you don't like gin why
this is not about him this is about you
bye
oh my gosh
I I don't know I don't know well you
know like if if anybody that calls into
your show they've got a history of
trauma yep
that's the healing
so you've got the immediate stuff that
you got to figure out in this in your
marriage okay you got a kid here and I I
would I would go to the ends of the
Earth to not be separated from my
children I get that that's chaotic and
it might mean that you draw some
boundaries then all of a sudden you get
shipped out of Australia and now you've
got you can't see your kid I mean I get
there's some International complexities
to your situation I get that okay I
don't I don't have any expertise in that
area at all so I can't even direct you
there other than to say
what you're providing for your teen
right now is this is what marriage looks
like
this is how you honor and love and
respect a woman this is how a wife
honors in in respects and and
communicates with her husband
and he's your son's worth more than that
also
and equally if not more importantly I'd
have to weigh that on a scale and figure
that out
you
deserve so much more than you're
allowing yourself to have
you deserve to be cherished yes but I
mean the way you're presenting that
sounds like it's out of out of a
magazine
you deserve to have somebody asks you
what do you think and what do you need
and to wake up every day trying to help
meet your needs and you waking up
everybody to try to help meet their
needs and probably in your past helping
meet people's needs got you burned or
got you taken advantage of
and so none of this moves forward unless
you do some trauma healing
learning how to set boundaries learning
your boundaries matter that your voice
matters that who you are matters
there's so much more love out there than
you're allowing yourself to have
my hope is today you call a counselor
there in Australia and you start the
healing Journey back from when all this
mess started when you were young
and then you say I want to develop
boundaries because I've got a husband
who is a Serial cheater and I allow it
and I just take it and I want something
more from me for my son and my life
and maybe that ends up being with him
probably not but maybe it does
but all of this starts with your healing
and hear me say this Jen
you are worth the healing